in europa wird gewählt doch viele
menschen können mit der europawahl
nichts anfangen
die eu das ist doch so weit weg und
total abstrakt das zeigt auch die
wahlbeteiligung die ist europaweit in
den letzten 40 jahren von über 60 auf
nur noch gut 42 prozent zurückgegangen
so weit so schlecht dabei geht europa
uns alle an
ich würde den mehrwert wenn man das so
nennen würde europas mit dem slogan
umschreiben ein europa das schützt und
vor allem die bereiche umweltschutz
verbraucherschutz oder auch datenschutz
was zunehmend wichtig wird in unserer
gesellschaft hier anführen die uns alle
unmittelbar betreffen als bürgerinnen
und bürger und natürlich auch als
verbraucher
man kann sogar sagen dass in vielen
bereichen die auch das tägliche leben
betreffen das europaparlament wichtiger
ist als das nationale parlament weil das
nationale parlament in diesen bereichen
eigentlich nur noch eu vorgaben umsetzt
in nationales recht beispiel
reisefreiheit gebührenfreies roaming
oder das verbot von einweg plastik alles
wichtige entscheidungen für unsere
zukunft zurück zur wahl alle fünf jahre
wählen wir das europaparlament
die wahl findet vom 23 bis 26
statt jedes land kann also seine wahl
gewohnheiten beibehalten die
niederländer wählen donnerstags wir
deutsche wie immer wieder sonntag ein
einheitliches europäisches wahlrecht
gibt es nicht die wahl ist frei
unmittelbar und geheim
jedes land welt nach eigenem recht mal
werden einzelne kandidaten gewählt mal
eine partei anders als bei der
bundestagswahl haben wir in deutschland
nur eine stimme die können wir an eine
der 40 parteien auf dem stimmzettel
vergeben
die gewählten vertreter schließen sich
je nach politischer zugehörigkeit mit
ihren kollegen aus den anderen ländern
in europäischen fraktionen zusammen
mit insgesamt 10 7 105 abgeordnete ins
europaparlament ein je nach größe des
landes sind es unterschiedlich viele
reiter oder luxemburg stellen nur sechs
parlamentarier ab deutschland bekommt
mit 96 vertretern die meisten sitze
scheitert der brh exit wächst das
parlament auf 751 sitze
das chaos in großbritannien überschattet
die wahl
dadurch gehen wichtige themen verloren
es wird zu wenig thematisch debattiert
es gibt eine zu starke polarisierung für
oder gegen europa also es wird selten
die frage gestellt welches europa oder
zu selten wollen wir eigentlich haben
wir haben sehr zentrale themen die
eigentlich im fokus stehen müssten also
wie geht es mit der eurozone weiter wie
gehen wir mit der flüchtlings und
migrationspolitik um klimapolitik die ja
auch junge menschen auf die straßen
treibt außenpolitische herausforderungen
in dem neuen internationalen kontext und
die liste könnte man verlängern
ein weiteres zentrales thema ist auch
dieses mal die sorge vor dem rechtsruck
in europa rechtspopulisten gibt es im
europaparlament aber oft schon länger
als in den nationalen parlamenten
sie sind also nichts neues die britische
youtube oder der französische front
national sitzen zum beispiel seit
jahrzehnten in straßburg und brüssel
aber es könnte natürlich noch mehr
zuwächse geben und dann das was man so
in einem bild als salatschleuder
bezeichnen könnte also wenn man den
salatschleuder dann schleuderte an den
rand dass zu viele stimmen an den rand
gehen und dass dann die mitte parteien
der mitte zusammen gehen müssen um
überhaupt noch etwas durchzusetzen im
politischen system wo es immer auch um
interessenausgleich geht von daher ist
ist das jetzt natürlich auch eine
richtungsweisende wahl für die rolle des
parlamentes und auch für die
gestaltungsfähigkeit der europäischen
union
bei all der schwarzmalerei gibt es aber
auch viele positive signale
das zeigen bewegungen wie pfalz of
europe die tausende menschen auf die
straße bringen
besonders junge menschen identifizieren
sich mit der europäischen idee europa
kann also auch begeisterung
[Musik]